[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much for coming and
I first introduced myself so I'm tram
from Samson Research UK and today in
today's talk I'd like to walk you
through our practices and also our
choices of technologies in building and
and IOT system with the prairies in mind
so to start the talk I'd like to present
your use case and we can use this use
case throughout the talk today so what
are we going to do is go behind the
scenes of the use case and look at the
technology challenges and other
solutions so first we'd like to look
Hector how to build Archie ok I will use
case basically the holiday homes in a
holiday result I think most of you has a
you know spend holidays event at home on
a big holiday result so we're talking
about this kind of scenario so to start
with one first that is how to build an
IOT system for one single holiday homes
so in our case we basically using a loud
we use survival things technology so we
can attack [ __ ] Mozilla LG platform
progressive education and the web
Bluetooth so once one LT was my was one
LTS beautiful one holiday homes we can
go to go further see how can we connect
all these songs together and furthermore
can we introduce some intelligence when
we build a holidays when we build a
holiday Connect holiday homes together
and appealed I would even a whole
holiday result so here and also we
observe in case is a to respect users
privacy so here we're going to look at a
federally learning and we're going to
look at the architecture for the whole
energy system and share with you our
current work status so you know holiday
scenario I think at this month only 2
min parties one is holiday makers the
other is the owner of holiday result of
the whole the owner could be just like
another another company and agents so so
what the holiday owners have in his mind
when builder our cheese for their
holiday result so first of all oh I
think when essential thing is how the
holiday homes very smart so easy excise
is a control and the provider passed the
services and then may abilities it has
been you know have to be compliant with
a legal requirement respect the user
privacy and the last but not least so
what is a with money side was is it
absolution cost-effective and does it
provide a long term benefit and from
holidaymakers the point view I guess for
housing such as the relaxed and easy
access is a control for the holiday
utilities and the facilities and also we
want to be relaxed and not being watched
we don't want anyone to monitor how we
use our electricity how many washes we
do every day
you know during holiday time so let's
look at how to build well I achieve one
single holiday homes and means privacy
in mind how is privacy doing in IOT so
house out he actually doing this privacy
really so the concerns are about risk
that help in the internet things has
opposed and data protection and the
personal privacy has been raised for
many years and and survey from ICO in
2016 has stated that
sakes int an Internet of Things devices
to
not properly tell customers how would
they have personal information is being
used this is pretty boring
the good news is at the government and
also the industry they are taking
actions for example in you GT here
I think everyone heard about JD Hogg
here yes yes the city park came in first
in May last year so this new new
regulation basically is to protect
personal data in law and also when you
design and you know and it's an create
new IOT solutions we need have a data
protection by design in mind
Oh previously known as privacy by design
so for y by IOT developers this
legislation has a significant impact on
how we think how we deploy our
technologies and what kind of services
were building so we're actually thinking
that well open web platform actually
promise it'll enhance the privacy
compared to other technologies purse
tags so we think actually Chile power
not only a challenge for web IT but also
a very good opportunity so what we've
been talking actually in you know many
people our Bible seems full maybe we'll
build our I achieve actually mainly
based on Bible things technology so what
is reliable things whether things
basically like let's just code from
Wikipedia it's the world is a software
architecture Estelle's
and programming patterns that along the
real world object to talk to world wide
web so it's quite a top lever so but
when we look at really he knows what he
sees is dress let's look at this so we
if you were a developer you know that
one of the major concerns in IOT is
interoperability because in a woman
suddenly we have a like how
so Farah from different vendors and
manufacturers something we want to
connect them together and they are not a
nice we follow the same spetic chains
the same standard that the public no not
even talk to the same same language so
how do you connect them together so
whatever things actually sitting at rest
is a soup I actually provide the
application layer solution so regardless
the difference you know in the night of
lock network layer physically physically
so a Barry mantises application solution
so which means that which means actually
is only it has to any other things it
talked you would connect how to talk web
so the scope actually Berryman at the
scope of IOT is a lot broader not every
thing in IOT they necessarily connect
web so we would like to think that
whether things actually is a option for
application layer solution for the
Tarpon for the traditional LG protocol
stack so the mobile thinks the basic has
been specification worldwide by w3c and
there are some implementation works
pioneered by Mozilla and Google I was
captured Samsung is also proactively
getting involved in this implementation
works as well and standardization works
so
so here we have actually a loosely
capita web of some solution for smart
home and we actually talked about syncs
gateway so coming since things get me
down this way
so since again we basically you connect
all your things together manage them and
connect to the cloud and we talked about
a control your things from your smart
devices like mobile phone through
progressive application we talked about
to have a new device new theme unfolding
so connect Imboden connects we are
networked through web Bluetooth so now
to look at this we just look at each of
these components in detail so first is
the sings gateway so I guess any of you
to attend either the Mozilla web of
things workshop this money yeah so this
gentleman was it was your impression on
the skirt yes it's a it's actually quite
impressive platform and those open salsa
so the this morning I did the workshop I
was there actually I think this mini
Leon talk about the gateway connected
way to things but actually the things
the things project is more than that
it's a basic story paths we have the
cloud server here since cloud since
Clara basically is a distributed a
collection of for cloud servers and
provided by Mozilla to connect the
devices across the geographical area and
we have syncs framework this things
framework basically is a collection of
reusable components to help you build
your own web things and we should
directly exposed wire web of things API
so they actually Mozilla creative this
Web since API spec become a document
that so to look at that's what they are
following and this come to the Kings
gateway the things get away is open
source applicant
and which helped to breezing existing
LTE devices to the lab so instead
architecture we can see that the back
handle for the things can have no Jess
so so no for Jess developers so this is
good news
and then the node.js actually can I know
Jess backhand talk to the front and the
strobe things API so HTTP and the secure
web socket
apart from jail energy as spotted by
posting section juice in another concept
called adapter this adapter actually is
a language adapter so long youtube
programming of things using other
language like a Rasta pison look at the
security side so basically the web of
the Mozilla things get away they don't
know you the things that framework
actually they colonial to establish HTTP
where Mozilla tunneling service so also
it allows you considered and this is one
way so apartment this is epic okay high
public okay infrastructure situation
so you actually you can tell the K from
your CAA say actually it's got to say
actually is less increment so you stand
it's a patch establish the clear ice
tunnel from your gateway to your class
Sarah let's consider another situation
so if you actually not on site you're
all set you actually somewhere in
remotely and then you want to access
your things at home so in this case
actually Mozilla provide this
back-channel back and the tunnel from
your cloud server your gateway using
paste cats so and the other thing this
is security cell and the other located
an authentication authorization aspect
away attach the following or house to
kind zero so that whole can because you
can choose a different types talkin but
how can they are using is a JSON web
token when I just wonder if you can show
the yet diagram again so this is
actually snapshot from well for our
applications so this shows that
screen pop up on the stinks owner with -
season when the third-party application
is well to exercise your things so the
things here it makes it Allegra all the
sensors in your home
so under at the owners screen we'll have
this screen perhaps so you can ground
the scope of the garage the access token
Sulekha I allow you to access a certain
things
oh I can actually follow there you can
check you on see actually I grant you
read access I can't quite grab your
attic access and owner knowing they can
do this they can also delete and the
rebook this tokens so this actually is
privacy least we can see no you got get
my content you feel under aspects the
scope of the since II won't ask me and
the full progress web application I'm
sure they're PW experts down here so we
actually basically the PW for mainly to
in our mobile phone each will control
devices so Peterborough basically is
about a website actually deliver nation
will happen look like user experiences
they basically advice Layton Layton and
Elise using native mobile applications
and the website and this new design
concept and API see the key features we
have seen here basically you can have
added to screen from promote this is a
basic nature a native applications
feature and they can do have offline
feature I've learned functionality so
although the function that is limited
that you can you can still show you you
know what was already historical there
you can still control something so this
online convention to be for us is quite
interesting because it's actually alone
you to give us the possibility to
minimize collecting store and using user
data as much as possible also you had
lost maybe you possibly know what data
is will be said in my device what is out
there so these features are basically
achieved
you know deploying a collection of
technologies such as a service worker
excel so but one thing is we need to
talk about another aspect for Security's
you can only serve your pages through
HTTPS so we talk about having new
devices onboarding is about the bluest
blue toast basically based on blue to
slow energy so the idea here is we use
the web Bluetooth API so to discovering
pairing and connect another mobile
Bluetooth device after that we went
occasion finished we actually passed
Wi-Fi information to the to the new
device and then along the new device
connected to the network through Wi-Fi
so what what was the reason we chose it
because the other thing is the rubber to
the server serves where HTTP and the
other thing is if we want to start
bluto's in discovery you have to do it
through usual gesture so this is another
aspect of privacy so we we had once we
have what I would keep you the for one
single holiday homes they were thinking
to how to connect them together connect
them together actually is pretty
understand and standard because you got
a cloud server your HD pew you that
cloud connect to your classical
technique change in this case mozilla
getaway actually already provided when
we look at the solution we particularly
look at how scalable the solution is how
come it can expand what we have in this
holiday resort use case can we extend it
to smart city case which has a millions
millions of devices connected either
scalability and the other thing is we
know data is very very very valuable so
how do we make a good use of will use
user data and then with respect of
the privacy so with this Amanda actually
we we want you to make good on for use
the data we want to do statics and we're
going to do predictions so with this in
mind we basically choose them federated
learning so a picker of you heard about
Federation learning okay so we actually
made pretty much using whether it's
learning in this IOT solution so what
happens the feather learning basically
is a collaborative machine learning
without a centralized the training data
so that the the basically the concept
was initially proposed under termed by a
Google in Google paper two years back
and decentralized we talked about this
centralized because we mention about
without a centralized the training data
which acting in these cases actually we
talk about a clients and a great server
so each client have their own local
training trim that model and privacy
we're going to talk more about pricing
like slice and the last point is a
possible personalized for you there so
basically if you can have your local
tree in the model and this there's
possibility for you to personalize this
model for particular users so in IOT
scenario when we look talk about privacy
majors are for client link and the
server we can talk about them together
in conjunction so the previously
features in the federal is learning
basically pretty much as next three
points selective update and at least
restrictive allow data updates so you
don't use you don't you try not update
and get updates throughout data rather
because you got through parameters and
you process the local data as close as
opposed
to the bakery sauce nice-nice explain a
bit more on this in the architecture so
this is actually have here to build a
IOT for the whole holiday result so
things between seems that an IOT gateway
Mozilla market away is enough Toto
communication so we are talking about
gate gateway or the harbor in each
holiday homes to connect with cloud
server
you know that server in the cloud and in
this case we call the client client is a
the IOT gateway and the cloud server is
an aggregate server in the term of
federating learning so what happens here
is the learning model located in each
gateway in each client and once we
actually we have the initial model in so
you have the Paestum here its historical
data and the tree in the mode initial
model in located you actually locate
them into each clients and they probably
the same for the cloud server once this
is in and the local gateway start to
trim their models according to the data
collected from this own house and update
this model so they keep on doing it and
what happens the a grid a server when
these need update is randomly select
search a certain number of clients so
that is basically it is not at this time
Nexen this times they stand next time
with no purpose three of them in this
time was selected another seven from
another group so the app days actually
the day we send the updates where
parameters the raw data will stay inside
the house and then the clouds are
basically according to the updates
collected the cloud server at a great
cursor where updates it's a mode
yourself once updated it will also
update the client models so sorry
so with mrs. King C man we can see what
is actually actually ejected meat was a
very permanent first the data doesn't go
out your house no data doesn't go out
her house
second the third the a great server
still can based on the model is tree in
the [ __ ] server started prediction
create prediction on statics so I will
work on for the religion in IOT still in
progress so at this moment we stopped at
a framework a bit inclined and their
server and also we actually manage it to
look at a cancer flow and the terrorist
surrounding Raspberry Pi story so this
is here I was just showing a simple
example actually way wrong under spider
8 server side we are we are in the
process actually doing him like a
utility usage in the house that the
model is not a fully rated here so this
is the model actually we monetize the
framework we're actually create the
single model just try to see how things
works so this model basic is to
recognize handwriting
hydron ten digits so what happens is we
show here basically the a great show
collect random eclectus updates from
three a selective random is like the
three clients and we see even parameters
that is actually a potato module so were
korea created here is actually the
statics for the prediction accuracy so
if we actually conduct the cystitis
snack shop in shop is a round nine or
ten so I Chris you can see in the top is
0.98 it's pretty good so actually we
actually run the we actually had a
hundred a hundred
and the accuracy pretty much on the
point seven point nine seven point nine
a turn like mark so this progress is in
is ensuing progress let me side and
actually we're updating in pretty much
every day so if you're interesting this
work you have a further work on days to
follow us we actually have another talk
in force back in London in July and my
colleague who is actually an engineer
specializing in federal earning will
join me then so we can discuss this part
further on them so that's pretty much my
talk for today thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]